all right let's uh let's continue um i
already told you
about some of the absolutely seditious
elements
and insightful elements and by that i
mean inci
not insight like oh what great insight
you have um
that donald trump posted to social media
yesterday
which were quite rapidly removed by
twitter as well as facebook and that
includes
a video in which donald trump says to
his uh violent riot
supporters go home we love you you're
great it was stolen
obviously this was what was going to
happen implying that the violence was
actually justified but
it's time to go home um twitter
and facebook suspended donald trump
for an interim period as a result of the
things that he posted donald trump was
suspended from twitter and facebook
for uh his tweets and videos to
supporters who were violently storming
the u.s
capitol trump posted the social media
message saying
he he loves them and that they're just
the best people but that it's time to go
home
he repeated false claims about election
fraud in those
messages and twitter said that it
removed
three tweets for so-called severe
violations of their civic integrity
policy now
earlier in the show we already went
through what these three items were
the first was a tweet in which donald
trump denounced his own vice president
mike pence
that by itself is historic and
outrageous in nature
and in so doing he included uh
in that tweet that there was all sorts
of fraud and pence isn't doing the right
thing that tweet was initially removed
by twitter
later in the day donald as the violence
grew on the capitol
at the capitol uh donald trump posted a
one minute video
saying it was stolen we won in a
landslide
but it's time to go home that video was
removed by twitter
and then later donald trump posted
another tweet in which he essentially
said and here i'm paraphrasing we read
the exact tweet earlier
this is what you get when you steal the
election that we won
in a landslide twitter also removing
that and then before we knew it donald
trump had been suspended for 12 hours
on twitter and twitter also saying that
trump's account will remain
locked indefinitely if those tweets are
not
removed also indicating that future
violations of the twitter rules by
donald trump
will result in the permanent suspension
of this account so
there is a micro story here and there is
a macro story here
the micro story is we've been wondering
after
january 20th comes and donald trump no
longer has what are called public uh
public servant
i believe it's called public servant
protection by twitter
is he going to get banned very quickly
and the reason that it's a micro story
is that
it really depends on for example does
trump even continue to tweet
a lot of people email me they say david
once trump is no longer president all
he's going to be doing is tweeting
he's going to tweet even more he's going
to need twitter as the bully pulpit
because he's not going to have the bully
pulpit of the presidency
others believe that donald trump is
being so
um i don't know what the right word is
disheartened
disheartened almost sounds like the guy
has normal emotions but that donald
trump is going to basically end up so
defeated and
shrunken by everything that's taken
place in the last few months
that we're just never going to hear from
him again once he is no longer president
so
listen twitter is making it very clear
that
if trump continues this stuff when he's
no longer president he's getting banned
from twitter altogether he has about 80
something million followers
and uh twitter saying we we will ban him
and okay that's that's interesting
the bigger story here is that
we have seen such a debasement
and coarsening of what is acceptable to
hear from our elected officials
that it has trickled down dramatically
and now
things that four years ago would have
been inconceivable from elected
officials
are considered sort of normal because
they're not as crazy as what donald
trump is doing and i'll explain what i
mean by that
donald trump is at the very peak
of this completely unhinged uh
uh unbecoming language and behavior
that we would expect to see from an
american president doing everything from
inciting violent riots attacking
everything from
reporters to his own vice president i
won't give you the list because it would
take me hours to give you the list
that is a new high water mark or
low bar call it what you want but in the
shadow of what donald trump has made
normal oh to some degree over the last
four years or at least expected because
he continues to do it
a whole bunch of republicans who in the
past
even through political disagreements
would have said this is too much
they now participate in either tacitly
defending
or repeating and sound and and signal
boosting
to some degree much of what donald trump
has been saying
and it we really saw it come to a head
yesterday
where only when these riots led
to our elected officials needing to put
on gas masks
to be evacuated from the house and
senate chambers only
then did some of them some of them mind
you
say you know what the six two-hour
objections about so-called voter fraud
that aren't going anywhere
we're we're gonna drop it uh we we have
to come together the violence has to
stop
and and and so they also
compared to the 2015 standard have
completely debased themselves
but in the shadow of trump's more
cartoonish debasement
a lot of them are getting a pass and
you're starting to see now and we'll
have some clips of this a little bit
later
you're starting to see so-called
reasonable republicans
start to put a dividing line in the sand
saying
the trump stuff is over the line but
what josh hawley has been saying and
doing is fine
what ted cruz has been saying and doing
is fine
and this goes back to something i talked
to you about in
really in november of 2016 where i said
it is going to be a fight to prevent
hyper normalization for the next four
years
we are as humans we are so adaptable
that crazy situations become normal and
they start to feel normal to some degree
and um you know to those of us who have
been wearing masks now in public for
many many months
it's it starts to almost feel weird not
to have the mask and this is because
humans by our nature are very flexible
and adaptable we need to make sure
that the ted cruz's and the josh
hawley's
by being five percent less nuts
than trump don't sort of get
a pass in any way and with you and with
me
they they aren't getting that pass but
there are lots of more
centrist types and folks who more
casually pay attention to politics were
sort of like
yeah yeah yeah trump's over the line but
the republican party otherwise is fine
no no no the republican party and
right-wing media
have been off the wall insane for four
years at this point and we have to
remember
we we have to remember not to forget
that as we get beyond donald trump